foreign
are things that go together well I mean
time is you know perhaps the most
mysterious ingredient in reality it's
more mysterious in space it's more
mysterious than matter you know a Saint
Augustine in the fourth century was
really puzzled with it by time and he
said you know what is time I know what
it is if no one asks me but as soon as
someone asks me to explain it I don't
know what it is and I think we're all
you know in the same boat now there are
thinkers who will tell us what what time
is
um the ancient Greeks Plato said the
time that genuine reality is timeless
that the world we live in is just the
moving image of Eternity and Aristotle
said no no time is quite real time is
quite real but it depends on motion and
change Augustine in the 4th Century
Common Era finally decided the time is
just in the mind that the past is not
real and the future is not real the past
is just memory the future is expectation
uh it's all in your head then Newton
comes along in the 17th century and said
no no time is utterly real absolute time
it's a sort of it's a sort of cosmic
grandfather clock ticking away in Blythe
autonomy Newton said uh absolute true
mathematical time of itself and by its
own nature flows equally without
relation to anything external
and then Einstein comes along at the
beginning of the 20th century and
completely refutes the Newtonian point
of view no there's no Cosmic grandfather
clock there's no Universal now there are
a multitude of times observers divide up
events into past present and future in
different ways and Einstein merges time
and space into a single fabric space
time and the mathematician minkowski
said uh henceforth the time by itself
and space by itself are doomed to fade
into mere shadows and what will survive
is a sort of a union of the two that's
the only thing that will preserve its
reality but now we would discover with
quantum theory that that's not so much
the case Einstein's Revolution is
unfinished tonight you'll hear a
disagreement as Lively as the
disagreement between all these great
thinkers I've just cited tonight we have
a realist about time we have an
anti-realist about time we have a
reductionist we have an emergentist the
whole gamut of opinion so you're in for
a real treat and without further Ado
first we have Lee smolen who is a
physicist PhD at Harvard and he's a
co-founder of the theory of loop of
quantum gravity Lee by the way no fan of
string theory welcome Lee swollen thank
you a native New Yorker
next we have a another co-founder of
loop quantum gravity a physicist from
born in Italy he is currently at the ex
Marseille University in France Jim I'm
here and here he is
um
also with us we have a theoretical
physicist who pursues research and
string theory okay and he's also pursues
research in theoretical Neuroscience so
the moral is if you're a string theorist
it's it's good to have a second
profession just in case
um
yeah
and finally we have a professor of
philosophy from Columbia the Woodbridge
professor of philosophy at Columbia who
has a PHD in theoretical physics from
Rockefeller University which is someone
once said Rockefeller University floats
above the other ivy league uh
universities it's uh it's kind of a
platonic Heaven David Albert he is a uh
it says here he is world renowned for
his insights into philosophical
questions about the nature of time space
and other problems Modern Family he's
not only world renowned I can tell you
he is renowned everywhere in the cosmos
except perhaps in Morningside Heights
David there he is okay
so let's begin by
David you're a philosopher and a
physicist so give us some insight into
what happened in the intellectual
transition from Newton to Einstein so I
guess there are two things that are
worth mentioning one is something that
happened with the Advent of the
Scientific Revolution and Newton's
Theory itself
um and that is that notwithstanding the
the your quote um from the principia
about time flowing equitably there's
the role the time plays in Newtonian
mechanics is that of a parameter is that
of the sort of fourth component you know
along with East-West north south up down
in the address of the physical event so
you really have a picture with Newton a
picture that that people often refer to
as a spatialization of time that is you
have a picture of this big
four-dimensional arena in which history
plays itself out in which any event has
this four component address and
it's not an exaggeration to say that
this decision to make time into a
parameter is is sort of the the founding
and characteristic gesture of modern
physics it's it's the gesture and virtue
of which modern physics can become a
quantitative mathematized
um Theory and it's a and it's an event
that in certain philosophical traditions
is thought to be the point that which
physics systematically cut itself off
from even the structural possibility of
ever getting at what certain people
thought was really the interesting
essence of time whatever it is we refer
to when we use words like flow or
passage or change or something like that
so that's one thing that happened
another thing that happened this is late
in the 19th century and it's Associated
especially with
Ernst ma who was a Viennese philosopher
and physicist Mark asked himself okay
what's what's something like Newtonian
mechanics supposed to be about well it's
supposed to tell us about how material
bodies move what do we mean by saying
how do material bodies move well how
they change their spatial positions as
time as time goes on is the time
parameter increases what does that mean
it's some kind of Claim about
correlations between the positions of
material bodies and what time it is and
then Mark asks himself
good and this is supposed to be a theory
which we're able to empirically test and
confirm I take it the way you test that
is you look at the material you look at
the positions the material bodies and
you look at what time it is and Mark
says I'm not sure I understand that
seconds thing what kind of access do we
have exactly to what time it is Mark
imagines himself in conversation with
somebody who says well what are you
talking about we have clocks we have
measuring devices for time that's how we
know what time it is and math says well
I'm not sure what you mean by clock you
don't mean a broken clock or a bad clock
or something like that the guy says no
of course I don't mean that I mean a
good clock Mark says what do you mean by
a good clock I the guy says a clock the
positions of whose hands are properly
correlated with what time it is and Mark
says but that's just what I've been
saying we don't have access to you know
it seems like we would need independent
access to what time it is in order to
decide what's a good clock and what's
not a good effort so Mark thinks about
this very deeply you mentioned Augustine
before this is there's a beautiful
passage in I think chapter 11 of the
confessions where Augustine gets
um gets himself incredibly confused
about this same question
um Mark thinks about this very deeply
and ends up saying that if you think
carefully all Newtonian mechanics is
about all Newtonian mechanics could be
about
are correlations between the positions
of material bodies and the positions of
the hands on on a system that has a
certain kind of structure such that
Newtonian mechanics will identify it as
a good clock so in the context of Ma's
work you get this
unprecedentedly
intimate relationship between time and
the operations of clocks a relationship
that's not well captured by thinking of
clocks as a measuring device for time
okay there's really some sense in which
all you mean by what time it is is the
positions of the hands on a device with
a certain structure and it was this
inside of moss that was terribly
important to Einstein in formulating the
special Theory the real insight that
went beyond Newton yes yes very much
went beyond Newton um um he was he was
dealing in the context of Newtonian
mechanics because that's what they had
been but yes very much Beyond and as
we'll see when we talk about special
relativity this kind of intimate
association between what it says on a
clock and what time it is turns out to
be crucial to the way Einstein thought
himself through special relativity
and Vijay it's your job to tell us in
two minutes uh or less
how simultaneity breaks down in special
relativity how you observers in relative
motion have different senses of time
right so
suddenly a special relativity is this
really somewhat fantasmagorical system
where uh the perceptions of the world of
of stationary observers and moving
observers can be very different in
particular moving clocks are supposed to
run slow compared to stationary clocks
now that sounds very mysterious and what
we're going to do today is we're going
to show you exactly how that works so
that you can reason it out for yourself
right so special relativity basically
was a system invented by Einstein to
account for the fact that experiments
show that the speed of light was
constant to all observers so we're going
to start from that and conclude that
moving clocks must run slower so let me
we're also used to this statement by now
that moving you know the speed of light
is constant but we don't think about how
strange that actually is
okay so imagine a bicycle that's moving
this way at I don't know five miles an
hour right it's moving at five miles an
hour now suppose you jog next to the
bicycle because you're the bicyclist
friend and you're jogging at five miles
an hour then pretty clearly if you're
the jogger at the my finger then clearly
relative to you the bicycle isn't moving
at all so it seems very clear that from
our everyday experience that the speed
of things depends upon your own state of
motion but for light that's not the case
no matter what your state of motion is
the speed of light is constant always
moves at the speed of light according to
you your perception and from that you
can actually conclude that moving clocks
must run slower and we're going to just
show that to you completely explicitly
here we have a special kind of clock
it's called a light clock we're going to
use light to measure off seconds so you
see the light ball going up and down
down and up down and up and every time
it goes down and up tick tock tick tock
it takes off a second so it's a very
special kind of clock where we use light
to visualize the workings of the you
know the hands uh the the arrows on your
on your wristwatch and in this way we're
going to track you know how time passes
using the motion of the ball of light
down and up down and up now that was one
clock so what we want to do is we want
to take two clocks both light clocks one
stationary and one moving and compare
them so here's a two light clocks so
there was this question of do you have a
bad clock or a good clock right so for
our purposes we don't really care if
it's a pad clock or good clock we want
them to be the same clock these two
clocks as you can see are completely
synchronized right they start at the
same time the light ball goes down and
up down and up and every time both of
them go down and up
you take off a second and both clocks
are clearly going at exactly the same
Speed The Measure time in exactly the
same way and this is our notion of
having the same time okay so now what
we're going to do is we're going to take
both of these clocks to one side and set
one moving and then we'll see what
happens all right here we go notice the
bolts go down and up down and up but you
can see that in the moving clock you can
see about the dotted red line that the
ball of light has a longer distance to
go to go down and up just because the
clock is moving now we said that the
speed of light is constant for everybody
right for the stationary clock and the
moving clock you should see that the
ball of light is still moving at the
speed of light but it has longer to go
so it must be that it reads the time
gets The Tick Tock ticks off slower
indeed you see that in that clock if you
look at it the moving clock registers a
less time than the stationary one
so we can play it again just to
emphasize that and you can see as you
see the clock begins to move
down up
down up both balls moving at the speed
of light but because the dotted
trajectory is longer down up takes less
time for the stationary clock than the
moving clock so the moving clock runs
slower so that's for the specific clock
but it's actually true for your
wristwatch too
moving clocks run slower
so now let me review of any excuse for
not having a complete clear intuition of
of this you should be more of Einstein's
theory that's that's what it comes down
to right you should be able to explain
this to your grandmother yeah
so maybe Einstein wasn't that smart I
mean it's kind of obvious um exactly so
here's where things get a little hairier
so you just explain how moving observers
moving relative to each other will have
a different sense of time that's special
relativity now we have the added Wrinkle
In general relativity that gravitation
affects the flow of time so Lee why
don't you uh give us a primer on that
and make it really funny
now there are five things that we need
to know about general relativity to
understand what the wisdom and the
debate that's going to evolve here the
first thing follows on what David said
the view of Mark that he described is
called relationality that's face and
time are not absolute as in the sense
and it's as being
given for all time for all space
absolutely whether anything happens or
changes or not the same space and time
are following the ideas of Mark who is
following the philosopher leibniz
aspects of relationships between things
that exist and things that happen
space is an aspect of the relationship
between things that coexist and time is
an aspect of relationships between
things that cause each other to happen
is one way of putting it and inspired by
Mark Einstein general relativity
realized a perfect
example of a theory in which space and
time are relational
so that's the first thing second thing
is it's the geometry of space as a
consequence of that is dynamical it's
not fixed it's not euclidean geometry
the way that you were taught in high
school or Junior High School
the geometry of space can change waves
can travel through it the geometry
related to time the rates at which
clocks tick can change not just because
emotion as Vijay explained but if you
put one one of those light clocks
further down in the gravitational field
and one of them up at the top of the
building they would click at different
rates so the space and time are
dynamical and changeable they're
contingent
the third idea is what Einstein called
the most beautiful idea he had in his
life it's called the equivalence
principle the idea is that if you fall
off a building you don't actually feel
the effects of gravity somebody falling
off a building is weightless and
actually I was very honored to meet an
astronaut today so I don't know if she's
here
but um to she was talking about how much
fun it was to have the experience of
being weightless and the experience of
being weightless of free-falling
is the same thing in deep empty spaces
it is outside a building if you've been
tossed off the roof of it before you hit
the ground
and that Einstein called the equivalence
principle and the experience of being on
the ground is the same as being in a
rocket which is being accelerated
uniformly
so that we feel not gravity we feel
resistance to gravity the floor pushing
up on us
resisting our natural motion to fall and
that is the equivalence principle now as
a consequence of that you can always get
rid of the effects of Gravity by going
into Free Fall that means that the
effects of gravity are more subtle and
have to do with comparing things falling
nearby each other which when there is
gravity acting real Gravity Fall
together or fall apart and that's called
curvature and the pictures that you see
of these rubber sheets involves
spiraling around the Sun and so forth
there's a lie there's a kind of lie in
that but the moral is correct the moral
is that gravity is a consequence of the
geometry of space or the geometry of
space and time being curved and the
fifth thing which ties everything
together although unfortunately since
this is and an entertainment preceding a
debate and not a class we can't explain
to you why these things are true but
deeply tied into the four other things
the fact that gravity is always
attractive unlike electrical forces
which can be repulsive or attractive
gravity is always uniformly attractive
so you got it
good
that's you're like gravity Lee you're
always attractive by the way the good
news and what he just said is that um
since the uh gravitational the strength
of the gravitational field affects the
flow of time
uh closer to the surface of the Earth
where it's stronger time passes somewhat
more slowly than it does higher above
the surface so if you like me live in
the basement of a tenement you age less
slowly than the billionaire who lives at
the 80th floor of one of those buildings
on 57th Street so I think that's good
good news
so now uh Carlo um tell us about you
know what does this mean for me general
relativity I mean you know we can make
slightly we can explain the precession
of the perihelion of mercury or
something but does it have any relevance
to our we have to ask this question I'm
sorry uh to our daily life to technology
well let me
let me start from repeating what you
just said but a little bit more slowly
because I think it's a it's key for the
whole discussion about time
um
you have to watch us I do have I have
one watch one and this can double as a
watch okay like to use it can I borrow
one of them definitely
forever or for now
I've known him for a long time
come back
well that's a good workout so for a
short amount of time okay so um
watches are supposed to
to measure the same time right
so what Jim just said is that uh if
these were a little bit more precise
than what they actually are
the following would be two that if I uh
take one Higher and keep one lower and
wait a little bit one two three four
five then I bring them together
they are out of phase
the one which is higher is a little bit
ahead the one which is lower is a little
bit late
now I want to make something clear this
is not a funny
consequence of a strain theory Dream by
Einstein this is something which is
measured in physical Laboratories with
clocks a little bit better than yours
and mine we have atomic clocks maybe we
can have an image or not because this is
an atomic clock which have a sufficient
Precision to measure measure this effect
at 30 40 centimeters 2010 this was
measured at 34 to 40 centimeters of
different of altitude so it's a fact
it's nothing to do with Einstein ideas
or our ideas about space time is a fact
that clocks any kind of clock anything
which evolving anything that happens
happens faster high and slower low right
so um I can get next slide if two
brothers twin brothers start off the
same age but one live in the mountains
and one live in the in the you can have
your
uh near the seaside after a lifetime
there is an actual difference of age
between the two which is very small
it's of the order of tenths of a second
so less uh but this uh it's true now
it's very small so we don't see it we
don't perceive it and that's why uh it's
not our intuition of time is wrong
because we don't have perception for
seeing these differences but it's
definitely there is measurable and uh
let me give you this story to see how
important it is when the navigation
system the GPS was first sent up you
know the GPS works with satellites
here's a GPS satellite in our cars with
these machines that get a signal from
the satellite and there are clocks up
there
so the clocks up there go faster because
time goes faster up there so the
physicists told the people who were
putting up the system
um which were in Los Alamos some
engineering scaffold because time goes
faster there so the engineers want to
implement that
but the GPS was done at the beginning by
the American Army
so the generals were in
charge of everything so they write the
report they read the report that they
say time goes faster their shoulder here
and they say oh come on we don't believe
that right because
so the first GPS satellites were set up
without taking into account or more
precisely with a switch which could or
could not take into account this effect
of different speed of time and without
keeping without taking this into account
the GPS wouldn't work at all the mistake
would be hundreds of meters or
kilometers so we're completely useless
so the UN intuitive ways features of
time are something which now are deeply
into our technology are essential for
our life we wouldn't be able to drive or
to kill enemies maybe that would be
better but so today even the the you
know US Army generals believe the time
is
by the way you wouldn't know it to look
at these mild-mannered fellows but
they're diametrically opposite when it
comes to the reality of time Carlo I
think is the biggest the skeptic uh on
the on the stage uh you the the
disbeliever in the reality of time and
Lee is the most robust believer in the
reality of time so I'm just giving you
the fireworks to come
um anyway I'm sorry we're good friends
anyway they're good for you yeah yeah
which shows you metaphysics can never
get in the way of friendship it's uh
um so why didn't Einstein have the last
word so we with special relativity we
have time and space merging space time
and then general relativity space time
is curved and that explains gravitation
um what did he leave unaddressed well
why don't you tell us Vijay because
you're uh you're trying to achieve a
sort of a working and bringing to you
know reconciling Einstein with quantum
theory right so that's so so let's see
so
a thing that has been implicit in
everything that Carlo and Lee have said
is that in Einstein's version of the
theory of gravity space and time are
physical entities they're like you know
thin they're things like you and me
right before that as you were saying Jim
right and as you were saying David that
the space and time were stages on which
things happen they're not dynamical
they're not really things they're just a
fiction a stage in which things work but
once it's a physical thing right then
you should think about the Dynamics of
that thing as you said the project of
physics is to take things and see how
they change in time
great so in the early part of the 20th
century it was discovered that the way
things move and change in time is very
different if you look at Small Things
versus big things big things behave in
the usual Common Sense manner you need
to throw a ball the ball goes like this
it lands there you know all the usual
stuff but if it could very if you look
at very small things then a theory
called quantum mechanics applies to them
and there are many ways to think about
this but one way of thinking about it is
if you look at truly microscopic things
then they don't stay put where they are
they sort of fluctuate they Ripple they
do things like this all the time they
sort of just fluctuating around so if
you accept this premise
and then if you accept the premise that
space and time are actual things real
things then you should somehow also
accept the premise that at the smallest
distances when you look at space and
time it should be Rippling and
fluctuating and doing all the things
that other physical entities should do
so one of the great intellectual
projects of the 20th century was try to
reconcile these two pictures can you
build a theory of space and time as real
things dynamical entities that fluctuate
and ripple using quantum mechanical
rules like every other physical thing
that we know so this is an exceedingly
challenging problem
and I'll tell you about three ways in
which uh the challenges have Arisen so
one way in which the challenge arose is
people try to apply the same methods to
carry out this project quantizing
gravity that they had previously used
for all the forces you know this
electromagnetic force a strong force the
nuclear forces and so on and what they
found is that somehow at the core the
theory became nonsense and it became
nonsense somehow because of the
assumption that the world is built out
of points that can come infinitely close
together in the way we usually imagine
so that led in starting in the 1980s the
whole series of developments that we'll
hear more about about approaches to get
around this basic difficulty and this
difficulty with building a real more
complete quantum theory of the object
called space-time is really dramatized
in particular physical situations you
know physicists like to have examples
where things become dramatic because
then you can really face up to the
problem and try to solve it and two
places where the just think this kind of
thing becomes really dramatic is with
black holes because matter you know
collapsing matter collapses to something
called a singularity where things are
very dense they have things called
Horizons Beyond which if you pass a
horizon you can't come back out so black
holes when you imagine that they are in
a quantum mechanical Universe produce
many many strange effects for example
time ends inside a black hole that's
very strange what does that mean
I'd like to understand that or solve
that another thing that happens is that
in a quantum mechanical world with a
black hole you lose information now
losing information is something that
actually goes against the basic premises
physics that you can't really lose
information you can't destroy it so that
produces another set of intellectual
problems and also another Arena where
you see these kinds of things really
come to the fore is the very early
Universe you know we believe these days
that there is a big bang there's plenty
of evidence that there was a big bang
and the Big Bang was of course a moment
in time where time sort of began and
where the universe is very small in some
sense and very hot and if you examine
what should happen there indeed space
and time if you believe the rules of
quantum mechanics should be Rippling
they should be violently pulling each
other apart you know all kinds of stuff
should be happening right and those the
results of those happenings should
somehow imprint themselves eventually on
the large-scale structure of the
universe under the night sky so we'd
like to understand all of that and so
that was the The Gap that's the gap
between quantum theory and general
relativity which tells us space is and
time or physical entities so that brings
us to the questions we are trying to
address here and so string theory is one
approach to reconciling
um theory of gravity with quantum
mechanics
um probably it's the it's I would say
the mainstream uh approach but uh
there's a slightly dissentient approach
called Loop quantum gravity and we have
the two Founders the two co-founders of
loop quantum gravity here on the stage
who interestingly are completely at
variance when it comes to the nature of
time but we'll get to that later first
of all just give us some idea I I I've
said Loop quantum gravity many times in
my life without really having any clear
idea of what it is I have some idea of
string theory because there have been
many popularizations of that so just
give us you know very basic notion of
what Loop quantum gravity is and how it
might bear on the problem of time uh why
don't you you start um Carlo and then
feel free to chime in okay I think Vijay
in spite of being a string theorist a
gay perfect introduction to the to the
problem and uh I praise from your
enemies is the greatest Praise of all
um and the way I see the problem is
exactly the way he uh formulated namely
um in in Einstein theory uh space-time
becomes like a sort of object it's not
an arena which is fixed there is an
object it's an object very much like us
or more precisely like light like a
little magnetic field and
the Dominic field was studied by Maxwell
first or at the Maxwell equation which
makes waves radio waves and everything
work in our technology but then in 19th
century we realized that the
dramatic field has Quantum properties
like as you said exactly in this small
it's it's fluctuating and it's discrete
because a key aspect of quantum
mechanics the the feature of nature of
the quantum mechanics started from and
uh clarified first is discreteness right
the discreetness of the Spectra of the
atom the discreteness of the
electromagnetic field the
electromagnetic field is made by photons
in some precise sense so it's actually a
wave but when you look into small or you
interact with it in the small more
precisely what you interact with is
chunks of Light which are the photons so
these things that looks like continuous
and oscillating scene at Large Scale the
small scale is is a cloud a sort of
cloud of dust who's grain to the photons
now what I said understood is that
space-time is a thing is a gravitational
field so it's very much like the
dominatic field in fact Einstein project
was precisely to redo for Gravity it was
Maxwell had done for electricity so
space now is a field is a thing but it's
also quantum mechanical so it's made by
grades grains of space
and these grains of space are the quanta
the individual quanta which make up
space and who's happening whose bubbling
uh make up space-time
low quantum gravity is a set of
equations
oh by the way they're here
they're eating here it's delicious
that describe the short-scale bubbling
of space-time and this is something it
built long ago which gives you an
intuition of sort of these are key Rings
attached to one another I I got all the
key rings in my hometown in Verona Italy
so there were no keyrings in Verona for
several weeks after this it was built
and uh um if you think that space of
made by little grains they they have to
know who is attached to who
okay so
um you imagine there's a little link
between each two of all these links that
are linked together so you get a
structure like this one and if you
follow a link in in a little round you
get Loop that's why Luke quantum gravity
they do flow quantum gravity is that if
you take generativity you take quantum
mechanics you discover that there's no
infinitely small there are this Quantum
space and you write equation for
describing this Quantum space and then
you try to use this equation for
describing
um uh what happened the scent of black
holes what happened the beginning of the
universe and hopefully to get
predictions that we can be tested
against experience I have a couple of
slides if they are there can I get one
this is the idea if you think about
space as a continuous thing you did in
the small the small down there something
happens something strange happens and
that's what we are describing this is
the chunk of space and these are the
links that connect them who says which
channel spaces attach one another but
the key Point that's the core of the
theory is that this chunk of space are
not like a photons that live in space
they are space so they don't live in
space they're all that it is
and space time is like a next one next
slide space time is just the The
Happening of the uh how they transform
into one another so against they don't
assume one another as time goes on time
is accounting of what happens the idea
is very much what David was saying at
the beginning it's not that the clock
measure time is it called we call time
the number of ticketing of a clock or
set of good things in the world that we
use as a reference for seeing what other
things happen and let me stop here so
we're now toying with the idea that time
is not a fundamental ingredient of
reality that it's something that emerges
from deeper aspects of reality and uh
yes the the you just presented us with
some an idea of the details of loop
quantum gravity but David I was thinking
you have a a slightly more abstract
approach to the to this that doesn't
depend on the details of any specific
Theory like string theory or Loop
quantum gravity of how time might be an
emergent part of reality yeah well this
I mean right I don't think this I think
this very much goes along
um with the with the sort of thing that
Carlo was just saying
um look here's a here's in in a very
simple way an idea of what kind of
strategy one is following when you try
to think of things like space and time
as emergent rather than fundamental take
a very prosaic thought like
systems that are far apart interact with
one another rather weakly okay and
systems that are closer together in
space interact with one another rather
strongly there's a very simple strategy
um an intellectual strategy of thinking
about flipping that on its head okay
um of saying to yourself
mightn't I think that in fact I don't
mean anything by being close together
other than interacting strongly okay or
I don't mean anything
by being farther apart other than
interacting more weekly and there's a
there's a so you can begin to see there
that you might you might take these
relationships that you're used to you're
used to thinking that say relationships
of interaction are as it were parasitic
on spatial relations but you could flip
that over and try to and and say to
yourself no maybe it's just the opposite
maybe what we call spatial relations are
really parasitic on these relations of
of dynamical interaction of systems with
one another and
um and there's a way to play this kind
of game with time as well we're used to
thinking of the dynamical laws of
physics as connecting the situation of
the world at some time with the
situation of the world at some later
time okay
um we're used to thinking of the
dynamical laws as telling us as it were
how the future situations are generated
out of the past situations but you could
imagine a similar strategy of flipping
that on its head as well you have this
big four-dimensional arena there's you
know there are there are there's matter
and Fields and so on smeared in some way
over this four-dimensional Arena and you
discover that there are ways of slicing
this Arena up into three-dimensional
slices such that the situation along one
of these slices is related by some
simple rule to the situation Along on
others of these slices and you can say
to yourself ah
maybe all I mean by calling something a
time is that it's one of these slices
that's related whose circumstances are
related in a simple way to another one
of these slices maybe all I mean by
dynamical laws are these rules that
relate the situation along one slice to
the situation along another slice so
that's I think
um in in a very simple way the basic
strategy that one has in mind when one
tries to imagine these things as
emergent rather than fundamental when we
have a picture don't we um we have so so
yeah we have a bad picture because I
designed it um but but here it is
um so let's see so
um so here is here's supposed to be this
four-dimensional Arena here are some
locations where they're where there's
matter for example
um at this point you don't see any Vivid
difference between one dimension and
another dimension but if you let the
thing go on a few more minutes you can
begin to see oh yeah there's something
special about this Dimension
um the the locations of matter are
lining up nicely along that Dimension if
you let it go on a little farther
uh uh you begin to say yes now I see
very clearly what's going on
um these things that were just places
where matter was are little pieces of
the trajectories of particles this is
clearly the time Dimension go on a
little further this is the part of it
that's really misleading and bad but
it's entirely my fault
um
um the particles interact with one
another in certain ways and once again
we're used to thinking of the strength
of the interaction as parasitic on their
spatial closeness but there's a strategy
one can imagine of flipping that on its
head and thinking of our notion of there
being spatially close as being parasitic
on the way that they happen to be
interacting with one another
um so that's supposed to be
um gestured at here where these
lightning flashes are supposed to be are
supposed to connote the strength of an
interaction so how many bong hits did it
take for you to get to that Insight
that's really pretty deep
so Vijay has a metaphor for explaining
aversion time
and it's a little meritricious but we'll
talk about it anyway it's love as an
emergent phenomenon and I know I
tell tell us give us a poem about how
love is an emerging phenomenon like time
you don't have to okay I will so so
listen so all of us have experienced the
emotion of love
and we think about it as you know a
cogent thing that we can talk about but
really inside your brains you have you
know a very large number of neurons 100
billion neurons which are doing that
little electrical thing they're firing
they're doing all kinds of stuff
so love isn't a thing for any given
neuron any given neuron in your head is
doing whatever it has to do to be a
neuron but the thing the construct that
you call love is sort of proper to the
collection of neurons it sort of emerges
from thinking about the whole Collective
so you can see how you know it's a sort
of it's a fuzzy thing love is right but
it comes out of the interactions in the
collective right so in this so we may
think about one way visualizing what we
want to mean or thinking about what we
want to mean by emergence of space
from something else or time from
something else is that really underlying
it the the constituents don't have
there's no notion of space or time
Associated to the constituents the the
concept of space and time is proper to
the relationship between the
constituents I mean so that that's I
think the kind of thing that you were
talking about right okay let's go to Lee
and Carlo I mean this really radical
disagreement between the two of you over
the reality of time and and as I said
earlier Lee has just written a book with
the critical legal theorist Roberto
Unger who uh and part of the gist of the
book I believe is your insistence on the
fact that all existence is in time and
there's time is real it flows it's not
um it's not something emergent it's part
of the reality as it is in itself and
Carlo
um says uh forget time time is um is
perspectival I mean you're closer to
being like I just to be a little bit uh
caricature a little bit like Saint
Augustine it's in our heads whereas you
say no no it's it's out there it's a
fundamental part of the fabric of
reality so I'd like just to get a little
debate going between the two of you and
um would you like I mean uh why don't
you begin with I mean the realism about
time is very unfashionable now I mean
you know you're the only realist about
time up here I believe we all think it's
an illusion right so so make the best
case for the reality of time
in how long how long she how much I
guess as long as as long as it's
interesting his deadlines let me go
first because I mean he's he's the most
dissentient heterodox voice up here and
he Because he believes in the reality of
time which all of us do I mean the man
on the street believes in the reality of
time right I mean it's rushing us
towards our death it seems very real so
there were three lines of thought which
converged to change my mind about this
because it's quite right
the standard point of view which maybe I
won't try to justify but it's because
it's very odd from my present point of
view is that the experience of time
changing the experience of the moment is
an illusion and that as Einstein put it
once in a letter to the Widow of a dear
friend of his who just died we
scientists know that the distinction
between the present past and future is
merely a starvingly persistent delusion
but really anything that is going to
happen exists anything that has happened
exists and they all exist together so
our dear friend is still here Etc I
don't understand why that was supposed
to be consoling but
but I I Einstein had his awkward moments
in personal relationships
um
so I I came I grew up with that view as
well and then it was solidified and
Carlo and I had the wonderful experience
of solving equations that describe the
timelessness of the quantum Universe the
so-called wheeler DeWitt equation and
this equation comes from the equation of
quantum mechanics which tells how a
system changes in time where time there
is defined to be a clock outside the
quantum mechanical system
and when you marry that to general
relativity and you take into account the
fact that in general activity the
universe can be closed so there's no
clock outside the system the
corresponding equation says there is no
change with respect to time
the quantum state of the universe is
timeless because there is no clock
outside the system with respect to
Define that change that's called the
will of the word equation and the act
that cemented the quantum gravity was
the discovery of that we could solve
that equation using these ideas of
discreteness and networks and Loops that
Carlo was
describing that we could actually find
an infinite number of solutions to that
and that's was the one I wish everybody
would have an experience like that it
was a wonderful experience to have to
have from a little while the feeling
that we knew something that nobody else
knew and then to get to to tell our
friends and our colleagues about it so
the wheeler DeWitt equation tells us
that the quantum state of the universe
is static yes right so so how do you get
time back into the picture now I'll let
Carlo do that next if you like because
one of the reasons
because I just want to indicate the
power of the idea and the strange to the
fact that I changed my mind I really
changed my mind because of a completely
other line of thought
and so let me discuss that and that was
a different question where did the laws
of physics come from
because in the 20th century in the late
20th century we came to the point we
knew enough about the laws of nature not
everything but enough to wonder why are
they like this why is the mass of the
electron what it is why is the proton
the neutron have a mass they do so much
heavier but with the neutron just a
little bit heavier than the proton why
do the different forces have the
strengths that they have and there's
about 30 questions like that about our
knowledge of particle physics where how
does nature choose the laws and could we
have an explanation for how nature
chooses the laws which was a scientific
explanation which meant that it had
empirical consequences
and I came to the view very strange at
the time that if we were going to
explain how the laws came to be what
they were how they were chosen it would
have to be a Dynamics under which the
laws themselves evolved and changed in
time
and then I realized that there was a
contradiction with our work in quantum
gravity because in our work in cloud of
gravity time emerges from these Timeless
laws from the wheel to wit equation but
the laws can change and evolve there has
to be a notion of time by which they've
changed and evolved
which is deeper than or prior to the
laws themselves because the laws it has
to make sense to say if the laws change
and so that was the idea that turned me
now I realized after a while in fact I
think it was you Carlo when I was
writing my first book about this who
sent me a quote by Charles Sandra's
purses he said you know you weren't the
first to think about this and I think we
have this quote here Charles purse who
was this for people who don't know the
history of philosophy the first is great
because I said the first Great American
philosopher yeah yeah maybe the greatest
American philosopher and he says
supposed laws of nature
capable of being apprehended by the mind
yet having no reason for their special
form but standing inexplicable and
irrational it is hardly a justifiable
position then he goes on to say now the
only possible way of accounting for the
laws of nature and for the uniformity in
general is to suppose the results of
evolution
and that was
1891. so I was shocked to discover but
not really surprised that this whole
thing issue had been thought out deeply
before and this was the conclusion that
this great philosopher came to and
that's the first key reason why I think
the time is real and not emergent
because if time were emergent it would
be emerging from Timeless laws and then
there would be no way in which they
could evolve and I invented a little
story about how that Evolution could
have taken place and while I'm diverting
from that you can show the second slide
I invented a theory analogous to how
cats evolve
and the only thing about that theory
that was the base of my first book Is
that that theory had empirical
consequences it mimics the role of
natural selection and evolution but like
natural selection Evolution it has
predictions and then I was left with a
puzzle how if you step back from the
idea that laws are absolutes the idea
that laws
are evolving can you get empirical
predictions from the mechanisms of how
they evolve and that confused me for a
long time so I realized that that's how
biology Works darwinian biology is much
more explanatory and predictive than the
previous biology because there's so many
consequences of positive mechanisms for
evolution there were two other reasons
one of them which David has written and
thought a great deal about is where the
irreversibility of our laws of nature
come from the laws of nature not only
tell you how to take the present State
and evolve it to the future is uniquely
well evolved into the past and and
posted what the past state of the world
was and by doing that we come to a
bizarre view that the past state of the
universe very early was extremely
special and improbable why was that and
in a Timeless picture it's very hard to
understand why there should be such a
distinction between the distant past and
the distant future as that implies how
could not just no notion of timers but
it is the strong distinction and a flow
of time an hour of time between the very
simple past and the very complex future
how do these things come to be now Roger
Penrose was posited back in the 70s that
the way that that very improbable
strange initial state of the universe
could be explained is that the laws of
nature had a direction of time built
into them the quantum gravity laws that
Vijay and Carla were talking about had a
directional time built into them but
that could only be if time somehow
existed at the level of the fundamental
laws if the level of time was emerging
from the fundamental laws
then the distinction between the past
and the future could not be written into
the fundamental laws because there would
be no time for them to refer to so
that's another reason that has convinced
me thinking about it the time has to be
deeper than the things which are
emerging from the laws now we agree I
think all of us that space could be
emergent but it's much trickier to get
time to be emergent with the properties
of time in this universe so let me stop
there there's much more to say about
these things but that sets up everyone
got all that that was a lot of heavy
ideas there um so um by the way this is
something I'm increasingly hearing that
that um from not just from you but uh
Sean Carroll uh the time is fundamental
space is emergent but uh so you're not
the only you're not the uh you know a
lonely dissenting voice in the desert
you have some intellectual allies but
Carlo you uh how do you take his
argument so the idea that the
um laws of nature evolve they're not
constant and this gives a a fundamental
role to time in the in reality as it is
in itself let me make it clearly and I
have been friends for about 30 years
more very good friends
yeah don't don't we can't do
arithmeticists
and we have been disagreeing always all
the time so we're doing a lot of physics
together we're happily doing physics
together and very often I think that the
disagreement has been one of the sources
of the common productivity I think that
science often works by different ideas
not by consensus but
um and here we disagree a lot we do
disagree a lot perhaps less than what
Lee thinks in my opinion
but still disagreement so let me start
from one point you said Carla doesn't
believe in the reality of time
of course this is wrong I mean time is
real I mean yeah okay wait wait a minute
um DJ gave a great example about
emergence which is love okay I subscribe
to everything Vijay said about Nuance
love does this mean that love is not
real of course it's real I mean we all
know that love is real right we're
always something extremely strong
um
I'm translating back from Italian
translation the weight of the world is
love
did you recognize this Alan Ginsburg
okay
wait the way you're on the tire I know
the Italian translation I'm really
translating things so I don't know
um so things can be real extremely real
without being fundamental that's the
point so when the the naive slogan time
is not real it doesn't mean the time
doesn't exist okay
a pen sorry for making over simple is a
fundamental thing of the world pens no
does this mean that this is not real
because it's real right it's very real
okay it's just not one of the
fundamental ingredients of the world so
Lee thinks the times the fundamental
ingredient of the world
um I think that
um time is real but not at the
fundamental level it emerges to
something it's like temperature
temperature is not one of the
fundamental ingredients of the world but
if you touch something hot temperature
is there and you get
so why do I think so
um and in which sense do I think and
then I want to go to the second possible
misunderstanding
um
I think the time
is not real and fundamental level it's
not one of the fundamental ingredients
of the world because I think that this
set of equations here the equations of
loop quantum gravity which are in my
opinion uh one of the possible
description of the reality of the
simplest level we've got so far
this set of equations don't have time in
it so time comes in uh comes in later
fact they don't have time in it and this
I go straight to the question you asked
at some point you said well the willow
David equation implies that the world is
stuck is timeless no it doesn't not at
all absolutely
so what's the point here
um well here it is so we measure time
with clocks okay with watches oh most
clocks have a little pendulum in it and
the point about pendulum
um is that each oscillation of the
pendulum takes the same time
that's why they're good clock
and the first person who sort of
realized that at least that's a
mythology mythology is Galileo Galileo
was he was sitting in a church in Pisa
listening to a
religious thing it was not very taken
probably by the religious thing and he
was looking watching this chandelier how
do you say in English it was a big
pendulum and he started to count the
timing of those the the the the the the
time of the selection using his pulse
okay and as the
chandelier is slow slow it down and was
less and less Ample Ample the
oscillations
the length of each oscillation was
always the same
okay so I said oh great to get something
this this is the story that Galileo gets
to tell how he got to the idea that the
pendulum has always the same period and
that's the good clock
except
and since I'm repeating what David said
before you know
few years later doctors were measuring
the pulse of the people using clocks
which have a pendulum inside
so you measure depending on with the
poles the pulse with the pendulum what's
going on I mean are we all hanging the
leopolds
for meaning what time is of course not
what point the point is that you never
see time you see the pools one two three
you see things happening you see event
the fact the time is not fundamental
doesn't mean at all that we're all stack
like that and nothing is moving anymore
it means things change
but the change is all there is
change doesn't happen in time if nothing
happened
if you imagine a world in which nothing
at all would happen
according to Newton time would continue
to pass one two three okay and some
clock in the mind of God would continue
to
I think that a lot of indication in
modern physics say that that's not a
useful way of thinking about the world a
better way to think about the world is
that the world is about happening it's
not about
static thing and if there's something I
slightly disagree with
um David the only thing is that I
wouldn't think that the world is a
four-dimensional Continuum these quantum
mechanics sort of more complicated the
world is about facts about happening
about processes
they themselves can be counted one two
three four four how many things have
happened and that's time
time is just accounting of the things
that happen and it's not something that
is pre-existing to defend to the
phenomena then we have this this
phenomenon happens we make laws the laws
are not absolute things out there in a
platonic World in my opinion it's just
the best we know about how things happen
so the second
um the second Point first time is real
but real things don't need to be the
fundamental staff of the world
second
um things happen but they don't happen
in time we never access time we only
have access you know clocks moving
things pendling pulses pulsing or
everything else happening in the world
and I think the best way we have to
explain so far the best
conceptualization we have the most
effective the one that gives us most
power to make prediction to understand
nature is to forget about this
time without things and just think at
the way things change with respect to
one another so these equations here the
equation of loop quantum gravity they
don't have t variable they describe in a
sense like if I had a you know a
position of the chandelier and the
number of pulses and the relation
between these different variables that
sense is relation of the picture without
having to choose something and call it
time
and just describing how things change
respect one another in this specific
sense it is my opinion that modern
physics indicate that it's more useful
to think about the world without having
to put time at the beginning
I know we're all thinking about the
famous scene where Groucho Marx is
taking the pulse of a guy and he said
either this man is dead or my watch is
stopped
sorry you were all thinking of that
um so Lee would you like to uh offer a
rebuttal to any of the points that uh
well you're right that we agree more
than I thought
which which is very gratifying
maybe we both moved a little bit we can
worry who's moved more
but we still don't agree completely I
don't think
so the question is if you start with
your world with which there is no
fundamental time but there's still
change there's still events
can you really reconstruct the world as
we see it and and here if we were not in
front of all these people who are being
very generous with their time to listen
to us we would evolve to a technical
discussion about what succeeds and what
doesn't succeed my sense is that
I I want a little bit more than you want
I want first of all the process which
makes the events continue to happen be
fundamental I we agree that there isn't
some abstract absolute time which the
things are compared to we're we're all
relationalists
but I want there to be some fundamental
attention paid to the process which
generates the new events out of old I
would call that the activity of time
I would like that activity to be
prior to some background notion of time
and prior to law
so I don't think that there's I think
rules and laws evolve out of the
accumulation of many instances of the
activity of time
I don't think the activity of time are
carried out or carrying out a
prescription
or a law and that's maybe the meat of
the disagreement there it's interesting
I mean the with the progress of science
the predictions grow ever more accurate
you know with Quantum field Theory we
can predict the outcomes of experiments
to you know 11 decimal places so there's
great conversions when it comes to
predictions but the metaphysical picture
we get from signs of reality oscillates
wildly you know with every Scientific
Revolution the old picture is completely
overthrown space and time emerge in
utterly new guys we have different
numbers of dimensions and so forth so
can we ever expect a kind of met we just
heard this very bold almost metaphysical
uh uh disagreement between between Lee
and Carlo on whether time is fundamental
or not so are we really are we doing
science now or are we doing metaphysics
and and do we have any reason looking at
the history of science where there you
know the the ontology the way the world
is in itself from one century to another
undergoes radical revision but
predictions grow ever more accurate is
the metaphysical picture we get from
science is that something we're ever
going to converge to you know an
agreement on and and maybe David and and
uh and Vijay would like to comment on
this uh there's a couple of
um a couple of places I wanted to jump
into the to the conversation that
um that Lee and Carla were having one
thing about Lee
Lee's view is I don't I'm not sure I
understand
suppose you took suppose you took a kind
of
um view of time as a parameter it's not
flowing but it's part of the fundamental
structure of the world it's not it's not
emerging
um we're we're used to talking about all
sorts of things changing with respect to
the value of that okay we have a sort of
spatial picture of what that change
means it's different at this value of
time than it is at that value with time
off the cuff I don't understand why why
the same kind of talk couldn't apply to
laws you you were saying that that the
thought that the laws might be evolving
put enormous put an enormous amount of
pressure towards a kind of
de-specialization of time towards some
conception of time as flowing or passing
or something like that I'm not sure I
saw why it puts more pressure in that
direction than the claim that that a
flower is changing over time or that uh
you know or that a piece of paper is
yellowing over time or or something like
that the laws are just another item in
the world that's changing with respect
to this parameter may I try it sure so I
would try to turn the principle of the
identity of indiscernible into a
dynamical principle and I have to
explain principle the identity of
indiscernible is the principle of
leibniz
that is based on the relational idea
that that objects are identified by
properties which have to do with the
relationships between other objects
and events are identified by properties
that have to do with your relationships
to other events perhaps the
relationships of causality and the
principle says that if you have two
events I use that word
which have this which have the same set
of relationships to other events or a
or the ones that are indistinguishable
then they have to be considered the same
we can't have two objects which are
identified precisely the same way which
are distinct
so I would take that to mean the
following supposing I have two
microscopic events that have isomorphic
that is exactly the same causal past the
set of events in their past that cause
them are the same
then to prevent a violation of the
identity of the indiscernible they have
to have different Futures and that means
that there can't be a law which is both
deterministic and local
because having the same past they have
to have different Futures I
so I think I understand all of this I
still don't see why it forces you away
from a conception of time as a parameter
because you could only make that
conception after you about the past
after you observed what happened you
could make a story about the past and
introduce a parameter discuss the past
but you couldn't use it in any useful
way to discuss or predict the future
you know
a lot of this discussion has been at a
very high philosophical plane
but most of us in physics are very
practical operationalists right really a
thing makes sense if you can use it as a
calculational scheme for making
predictions for you know Computing
things so one thing that I think that is
we've not perhaps completely addressed
is what that would mean in terms of time
being emergent and what kind how you
would use it in some sort of predictive
way and things of that kind so I think
it's first important to state that in
something like string theory which is
another approach to quantum gravity in
most approaches to string theory you
know space and time are taken as you
know operationally real I mean just
there there's no need to talk about
emergence it's a stage and really what
those in that field you do
is the following so you know here's this
surface of the stage you know if I kick
it a little Ripple runs off and you can
build the quantum theory of those
ripples you can do that with space you
Bank space a bit and these little
ripples run off and you call those
gravitons and you build a quantum theory
of those ripples but in the language
that I just used the space and time are
pre-existing right they're there right
it's not addressing these deeper
questions that Carlo and Lee have been
talking about is where did the space and
time come from you take it to be there
and the project is to build the theory
of the ripples on that
so so and that's because operationally
you can you know you can calculate right
and there's a there's a space there's a
time you make a little bump in it the
bumps move along and they bash each
other you calculate right and physicists
are very like to do that now in terms of
emergence indeed as you were saying
there are completely concrete examples
and string theory of emergence of space
so it's useful to visualize what that
means to then talk about why you know
emergence of time is such a more
complicated thing imagine here's a
two-dimensional world right there's a
person in it very easy for us to imagine
now here's the next slide
here's a three-dimensional world like
ours and there's a person in it
right now suppose you want to imagine
the Third Dimension the one coming out
as kind of emergent from the lower
Dimensions what do you do well here's a
picture uh here's a third slide so
imagine now this is just to visualize
this right that this two-dimensional
world
is sort of sitting at the edge of this
three-dimensional world like you'd
imagine that now we're going to talk
about how the three-dimensional part of
the world may be emergent from the
physics or the Dynamics of these two
Dimensions right we're going to think
about both of these as real descriptions
right so here's a picture
um there's the person living in the
three-dimensional world and look at
their shadow in the two Dimensions if
there was a way in which you could
describe all the Dynamics and every all
the physical phenomena equivalently in
terms of the three-dimensional person or
in terms of their Shadow right then you
could ask the question is the three
dimensions real or is the two Dimensions
real and how do the Third Dimension come
out from the description of the second
dimension of just two dimensions and
usually and so in string theory there
are examples where indeed there's a
three-dimensional world
um the Shadows of the three-dimensional
creatures the ball in this case in the
two-dimensional World equivalently
represented and if the ball is close to
the edge of the world then the shadow is
small as you see in this picture and if
you're but if the ball is far away the
shadow is Big so what happens is that
things that are locate the third
dimension right get somehow represented
in the size of the shadow in the lower
dimensional world that by the way that's
not at all trivial you might say oh it's
just light shining from above and you
know you make the shadow not at all
trivial because you know in the third
dimension two things that are separated
in the third dimension in the up
Direction can move past each other
without touching the kind of thing you
were talking about they don't interact
so that's what operationalizes the fact
that they're in different locations so
now I'm telling you that there's a
description of the same physics in two
Dimensions where the far away object is
a Big Blob and the nearby object is a
small block but somehow you have to
arrange it so when they pass through
each other even though they're in the
same place
in two Dimensions because one is small
and one is Big somehow they don't
interact and then you could
operationalize the fact that they don't
interact in the two Dimensions as saying
really their apartment in three
dimensions now you know you might hope
to use that kind of operationalization
to somehow come up with a notion of time
because time is associated with
causation right two things can influence
each other in time but that has proved
very challenging right so this is what
has been driving some of your remarks
like translating this kind of insight
which this is a you know physicist is
also like examples once I have an
example I feel like oh I'm on safe
ground I have one example that works
I'll generalize from this so you have
lots of examples like this in space
getting a version of this for time has
proved much more challenging because you
would need a Timeless Theory
right something without a time in it in
which you need to represent objects in
such a way that they effectively carry
out these sort of causal interaction and
things can if they're far away they can
interact after a certain amount of time
so operationalizing that in that kind of
sense has proved hard so I just want to
emphasize that you know all of this talk
about you know is time emergent is it
real Etc sounds very philosophical but
at the end of the day you know uh I
think all three of us are very practical
people as in the end of the day you have
to be able to calculate what happens and
explain the different descriptions and
hopefully come up with an experimental
signature that says if it's this picture
or that picture you'll find something in
the cosmic microwave background or in
the large-scale structure of the
universe or in a very careful
observation of a black hole that really
distinguishes these theories
so you're happy that with the idea that
ultimately the seemingly philosophical
differences will be resoluable with
evidence well that's what it takes for
it to be science
can I comment on that yeah yeah please
do
um
yes but I think you're putting a little
bit too stronger that the philosophical
disaster
um resolved by
um
definitely I think I I fully agree that
at the end of the day uh and I think Lee
also agrees entirely and even David
who's a philosopher against entirely
um a large part of the interest of this
game is to write down equations that
make predictions then you make an
experiment and say okay that was right
um and this is what the great physicists
of the past succeeded in doing you know
from uh Newton all the way to five and
after
um but if you look the way they worked
if you look at the way Newton and
Faraday Einstein Heisenberg worked is
not just you know write an equation say
does it match with prediction not at all
very often there was a lot of conceptual
work trying to figure out a set of
notional Concepts that would work for
for understanding the the phenomena that
we're studying the book of Newton has a
huge philosophical discussion at the
beginning against the card exactly about
the notion of space and time Faraday has
a big discussion about his electric and
magnetic field are the electromagnetic
field real okay yes no for this reason
and Einstein goes on and on about his
influences Mark and ship an hour even
and Heisenberg the same so I think the
way
um I think the pro the way I would
phrase this is the following we we know
something about the world so we make a
conceptual structure for thinking about
it it works then we learn something else
and say well this doesn't work anymore
can we make a better one
so we choose a better we we search a
better set of notion Concepts this is
with this we choose is fundamentals this
we choose and with this and then of
course the point is that do it are we
capable of coming up with a vision a
conceptual structure a set of equations
that stay together and test them against
reality okay Iceland did that and the
test again reality was spectacularly
successful so instead of thinking flat
space blah blah he came out with idea
space is a field huh and he has a set of
prediction rules that's what we would
all like to do right and if I may that's
um what we're all
failing so far right you like me like
Lee
um we hope that we're just failing for
the moment
um going ahead what I'm doing right now
is using these ideas for computing what
happened to a black hole that collapses
what happened in the middle which Vijay
said is one of the you know one of the
point of quantum gravity issue so in the
middle space and time go wrong in some
sense
um wrong enough for allowing uh
space-time to change and becoming a
white hole and coming out and producing
the signal that we're trying to compute
and check against observations it's a
long shot if it works if the observation
match with the predictions of this you
know bouncing black holes then it means
the set of ideas I wouldn't say a right
but are a better way of thinking reality
a more effective way of thinking reality
what we were using before in that case
for instance if you're in the center of
a collapsing star the time for you is an
almost shorter than the time for
somebody outside so this flexibility of
thinking about time locally rather than
globally helps may have might help
because it hasn't yet to understand a
phenomena at the end of the day is data
and measurement that make a way of
thinking more effective or less
effective we have three more minutes and
there's there's one curiosity of what
you would I was just going to go back
no I just the the
um when you start studying uh special
relativity often you get diagrams where
there's one dimension of time and one
dimension of space and everything is
nice and symmetrical but we evidently
live in a world where there is one
dimension of time in three dimensions of
space and we may live in a world if
strength if there is right whether there
are
nine or ten dimensions of SP of space in
one dimension of time why is it that
what breaks the Symmetry between space I
mean I can walk around the chair to get
to you but I can't walk around Tuesday
to get to Wednesday and I does anyone
have any thoughts I have a couple of
comments
so so so so so for starters you know uh
I think the breaking of that symmetry is
put in by hand as far as the mathematics
of many of these theories goes you can
have two times three times as many times
you want in fact I think one time in
three space seems very inelegant to me I
wish there were two times in two space
it feels more symmetric two-dimensional
time you you can write down a set of
equations that describes the Dynamics
and such things you know yeah
be peculiar about the Dynamics
everything's striking I assume I'd feel
different but but if I might make one
more comment right I mean a thing that's
worth saying is the way in which most
physical theories Quantum field theories
like standard model of particle physics
that you talked about earlier are
defined is actually you get rid of time
you first pretend that it's for spatial
Dimensions you calculate everything and
then there's a mathematical trick of
putting the time back in all of this
kind of thing really makes me feel that
we're sort of Faking ourselves out about
the reality of time in some way we
really calculate typically in physics
operationally as if there's no time and
then and then there's a trick
to put time back in I think Lee wants to
say something but I'm not looking at him
that way he I don't have to notice it
right go for it if you could feel it in
the back of your head you know I quoted
Einstein as saying that the difference
between the past present and future was
this stubbornly persistent illusion but
Einstein was also quoted by the
philosopher karnaf as expressing a great
deal of misgiving about the idea that in
general relativity and contemporary
Notions of physics
time in the sense of Passage as David
said in the present moment
is optional it can be taken out of the
picture and you can still have a picture
which is explanatory and so forth and
my view
and I'll just state it baldly there are
many reasons for it and there are many
different ways that I come to this View
is that Einstein the second Einstein was
right was was thinking more correctly
was thinking more deeply and when we
finally understand these things
we will have a view of time as essential
in a way that it can't be removed and
the notion of the present of Passage is
the objective distinction between the
past and the present will be fundamental
to physics as an operational
experimental level that's my dream
and we don't know obviously we have to
end up any discussion like this by
saying we're just scientists caught at a
moment of time in a tradition in a
process we don't know which ideas are
going to turn out to be right but we're
confident that I think we all share this
we're confident in the power of the
tradition of science to come eventually
to consensus when we're forced to by
experiment and we hope that that will
come even with these difficult questions
and now we have to go to commercial
um but I think the last word
um we have nothing but physicists us up
here so let's give the last word to a uh
to a composer uh Hector berlios who said
um time is the greatest of teachers but
unfortunately it kills all its pupils
um so thank you all very much and
Brilliant discussion
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign